Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Uccak.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig
und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesigespräch durchführen.
Damit sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin einverstanden.
Ok, danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie
etwas nicht verstehen. Ok?
Ok.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Friedrich Loeffler.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam beschreiben?
F R I I D R I C H
Friedrich Loeffler L Ö Umlaat F F L I R
Ok. Herr Loeffler, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 64 Jahre alt, Doktor.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
12. Oktober 1968.
Entschuldigung, 1961.
1961, ok. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 Kilogramm.
Wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
Entschuldigung, ich bin 1 Meter, 78 Meter.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
74 Kilogramm schwer.
Ok. Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Ja, meine Hausart hört...
Ich vergesse jetzt, Doktor.
Ich vergesse jetzt, wie er heißt.
Nein, jetzt ist es nicht...
Ok, alles klar. Herr Loeffler, wir können nach dem Aufnahmegespräch darüber widersprechen.
Ok.
Herr Loeffler, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Heute Morgen ging es mir plötzlich schlecht, Doktor.
Ich habe angefangen zu zittern, mir war schwindelig und ich habe stark geschwitzt, Doktor.
Ich bin sehr schlecht.
Also seit heute Morgen schwitzen Sie zu viel?
Ja.
Haben Sie zittern und schwindelig?
Ja, ja.
Ok. Haben Sie zittern in den Händen oder?
In den Händen?
Ja, in beiden Händen.
Herr Loeffler, haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, das ist das erste.
Ich war mit meinen Freunden auf einer Fahrradtour heute Morgen.
Aber plötzlich habe ich sogar den Namen meines Freundes vergessen, Doktor.
Ok. Herr Loeffler, können Sie bitte Ihre Beschwerden genau beschreiben?
Gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für diese Beschwerden?
Haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe etwas nicht bemerkt.
Gibt es einen Auslöser für diese Beschwerden, Doktor?
Ok. Sie haben heute eine Fahrradtour mit Ihren Freunden gemacht.
Ja.
Haben Sie dort eine Verletzung zum Beispiel?
Nein, nein. Ich habe keine Verletzung.
Aber plötzlich fühle ich mich schlecht.
Und ich habe plötzlich angefangen zu zittern.
Ok. Herr Loeffler, haben Sie heute Morgen etwas gegessen?
Ich meine zum Frühstück?
Ja Doktor, Sie haben recht.
Ich denke, ich habe heute Morgen nicht richtig gefrühstückt.
Vielleicht liegt es da an, ich denke.
Haben Sie etwas gegessen oder nichts?
Nicht richtig gefrühstückt.
Ich habe ein bisschen Brotchen gegessen.
Ich denke, ich habe heute Morgen nicht richtig gefrühstückt.
Ok. Herr Loeffler, also darf ich fragen, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen
wie zum Beispiel Blut-Sukker-Krankheit?
Ja, ja. Sie haben recht Doktor.
Ich habe seit 3 Jahren Diabetes Type 2.
Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ein Medikament oder Insulin?
Ja, ich nehme mit vor mir 500 mg morgens eins.
Und dazu spritze ich 20 Einheiten Insulin nach dem Essen.
Ok. Haben Sie heute Morgen nach dem Frühstück Insulin gespritzt oder?
Ja, ja. Ich habe gespritzt.
Ich nehme mit vor mir einen.
Ich habe mit vor mir genommen.
Ok. Alles klar. Also wenn ich alles richtig verstanden habe,
Sie haben zu wenig zum Frühstück gegessen.
Trotzdem haben Sie Insulin gespritzt und ein mit vor mir ein.
Ja, ja, ja Doktor.
Ich habe andere Beschwerden Doktor jetzt.
Ich sehe alles verschwommen und war sehr unruhig.
Mein Herz hat schnell geschlagen.
Und ich hatte so ein Krippen in den Finger.
Sind Sie verstanden?
Ja. Alles klar.
Herr Löffler, haben Sie auch Lähmungen in den Armen oder Beinen bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Aber ich hatte so ein Krippen.
Ja, ja. In den Fingern.
Ok. Herr Löffler, ich möchte das Anamnesengespräch hier unterbrechen.
Also ich denke, das ist eine Notfallsituation.
Ich möchte Ihr Blutzuckerwerte messen.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte das Anamnesengespräch unterbrechen.
Ich denke, der Patient leidet unter niedrigem Blutzucker.
Deswegen möchte ich die Blutzuckerwerte messen und weitere Ersnahme,
weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Wie zum Beispiel mit der Parameter überwachen.
Aber ich bin jetzt in der Prüfung.
Deswegen möchte ich die Prüfung weitermachen. Darf ich?
Ja bitte.
Danke.
Herr Löffler.
Ja.
Ok. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie inneren Unruhe haben,
Hesrasen und auch Kribbeln in den Fingern.
Ja, ja.
Leiden Sie auch unter Luftnot oder Husten?
Ich habe keine Luftnot unter Husten.
Aber ich war auch seitlich etwa disorientiert.
Ich wusste zum Beispiel nicht mehr genau, ob heute Montag ist oder nicht.
Ok. Also in welchem Lebensjahr sind wir?
Herr Löffler, darf ich fragen?
Wissen Sie?
Können Sie bitte wiederholen, Doktor?
In welchem Lebensjahr sind wir?
Ja, 2024 oder 2025.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, Doktor.
Ok. Also sind wir im Winter oder Frühling?
Wissen Sie das?
Ich habe stark gewusst.
Ich denke es ist Sommer.
Ok. Alles klar.
Herr Löffler, leiden Sie unter Kopfschmerzen?
Kopfschmerzen? Nein.
Oder Nackensteifigkeit?
Ja. Nein. Ich habe keine, Doktor.
Leiden Sie unter Hörstörungen?
Hörstörungen? Nein.
Ok. Aber Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie unter Sehstörungen leiden.
Ja. Ich sehe alles verschwommen.
Aber ich habe keine Hörstörungen, Doktor.
Ich höre Sie gut.
Alles klar. Das freut mich.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüterfrohs oder Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe immer stark geschwitzt, aber ich habe andere Schwerte, keine.
Leiden Sie unter Kaltschweiß?
Ich habe keine Kaltschweiß.
Ok. Und leiden Sie unter Brustschmerzen oder enger Gefühl in der Brust?
Ich habe keine Bemerkungen, nein.
Ok. Das freut mich.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Löffler?
Ich habe keine Appetitlosigkeit, Doktor.
Ich möchte viel Essen essen, aber ich habe Zuckerkrankheit.
Ich verstehe.
Also Sie haben Heißwung?
Ja.
Ok. Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ab- oder Zuck genommen?
Ja, Doktor. In den letzten drei Monaten habe ich drei bis vier Kilo abgenommen.
Und ich habe ständig Durst.
Bitte? Sie haben?
Ständig Durst.
Ok. Alles klar.
Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ich habe keine Übel und erbrechen, nein.
Was ist das Problem mit Wasserlassen, Doktor?
Ich muss auf die Toilette gehen.
In der Nacht?
Ich habe keine Krankheit.
Meinen Sie in der Nacht?
Ihr habt nicht richtig verstanden?
Ich muss häufig auf die Toilette gehen, ja.
Wie oft gehen Sie zum Wasserlassen, darf ich fragen?
In der Nacht gehe ich mindestens drei oder viermal, Doktor.
Ok.
Ich habe natürlich Schlafstörungen.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Stuhlgang? Nein.
Ok.
Herr Loeffler, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie an Zuckerkrankheit leiden.
Sonst haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Seit drei Monaten habe ich außerdem einen Hautpilz in der Achselhöhle, Doktor.
Den habe ich mit einer Kanestensalve behandelt.
Ok. Und sonst?
Vor 13 Jahren hatte ich einen Unfall.
Bei dem habe ich mir das Sprungbein gebrochen.
Das wurde konservativ behandelt.
Aber seitdem habe ich Atrose.
Ok. Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament?
Ja, bei Betaf nehme ich die Clophenac.
Ja.
Ok. Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Aber ich weiß gerade nicht genau, wie viel nehme ich.
Ok. Kein Problem.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein.
Ich habe keine operiert worden. Nein.
Ok. Herr Loeffler, haben Sie Allergie?
Allergie? Ja, ich bin allergisch gegen Pferdhaare und Penicillin.
Pferdhaare und Penicillin.
Also, wie aussehen Sie diese Allergien, darf ich fragen?
Ich meine Pferdhaare zum Beispiel?
Ja, das ist die Schmerzen und Atemnot.
Und Penicillinallergien?
Wenn ich Penicillin nehme, ist meine Lippe schwoll und ich habe eine starke Atemnot.
Ja, Doktor.
Ok. Alles klar.
Herr Loeffler, ruchen Sie?
Ich habe früher etwa 20 Zigaretten am Tank geraucht.
Aber seit drei Jahren habe ich das reduziert.
Jetzt rauche ich noch fünf bis sechs Zigaretten täglich, Doktor.
Ok. Und haben Sie...
Wie lange haben Sie 20 Zigaretten täglich geraucht?
Ich meine früher.
Ja, ich denke, etwa 30 Jahre.
Ok. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, früher habe ich auch ein bis zwei Flaschen Bier pro Tag getrunken.
Heute habe ich nur noch gelegentlich am Wochenende oder in einem Verein.
Und wie viel trinken Sie am Wochenende?
Ein Flaschen Bier.
Ok. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Drogen habe ich nie konsumiert, Doktor.
Ok. Herr Loeffler, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite im Sozialdienst als Angesteller.
Ok. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin seit 18 Monaten verfitfert, Doktor.
Herr Wittwerth, es tut mir leid, dass Sie hören.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Zwei sind gesund, aber meine Tochter leidet unter Angststörungen.
Ok. Herr Loeffler, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater ist mit 69 Jahren an Nasenne-Benn-Höhlekrebs gestorben.
Wie ist das?
Nasenne-Benn-Höhlekrebs.
Na?
Meine Tochter lebt im Pflegeheim.
Sie ist bettlägerig und hat ein großes Drucksgeschwister.
Alles klar. Es tut mir leid, dass Sie hören.
Für Ihr Vater und Ihr Mutter.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe zwei Geschwister.
Bruder oder Schwester?
Ein Bruder und eine Tochter.
Eine Schwester.
Sind Ihre Geschwister gesund?
Ja, alles ist gesund.
Herr Loeffler, das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, was habe ich?
Herr Loeffler, ist es zu früh etwas genau zu sagen?
Ich vermute, dass Sie eine niedrige Blutzucker haben.
Und wir werden kontrollieren, ob Sie ein Problem mit Gehirn haben.
Das ist auch sehr wichtig bei uns.
Deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Dann werden Sie mir ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Aber machen Sie bitte keine Sorgen.
Sie sind jetzt bei uns in guten Händen.
Wir werden alles tun für Sie, Herr Loeffler.
Muss ich in Krankenhaus bleiben oder Doktor?
Ja, Herr Loeffler.
Ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben.
Damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können.
Und eine Therapie einstellen können.
Wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden,
dann können Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Okay?
Was ist gefährlich, Doktor?
Ich habe nicht gefährlich gesagt.
Ich habe Ausfälliges.
Ich habe falsch gehört, Doktor. Danke.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz.
Ich bin gleich wieder da, Herr Loeffler.
Danke schön, Doktor.
Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne über ihn berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön.
Der Herr Loeffler ist 64 Jahre alt.
1,78 Meter groß und 74 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Loeffler stellte sich heute bei uns.
Wegen seit heute Morgen bestehender Tremor in den Händen.
Er hat eine Artigo und Hyperhydrose vor.
Dem Patienten zufolge habe er heute Morgen
mit seinen Freundinnen eine Fraktur gemacht.
Bevor dieser Veranstaltung habe er zum Frühstück
nur ein bisschen Brötchen gegessen.
Trotzdem habe er 20 Einheiten Insulin gespritzt
und er habe 500 Milligramm Metformin eingenommen.
Während des Fahrradtours hatte er genannte Beschwerden.
Er berichtete über innere Unruhe,
Tachikardie, Parasthese im Finger und Sehstörungen.
Die Fragen nach Dyspnoe, Tussis, Sephalgie, Nackensteifigkeit,
Höchststörungen, Angina Pectoris und Endegefühl in der Brust wurden verneint.
Der Patient habe den Namen von seinen Freundinnen vergessen
und er disorientiert während des Anamnese-Gesprächs.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgen bekannt.
Gewichtsabnahme von 3-4 Kilogramm innerhalb von 3 Monaten
Nükzüri 3-4 Mal, Insomnie, Heißhunger und Durst.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit 3 Jahren bestehender Diabetes-Mellitus Typ 2.
Seit 3 Monaten bestehender Tinea Axillares
und vor 13 Jahren diagnostizierte Schuprunklenfaktor bei einem Unfall.
Seitdem leidet er an chronischer Arthrose.
Er nimmt regelmäßig Metformin 500 mg morgens und Insulin 20 Einheiten morgens spritzen
und er benutzt Cannisten Salbe gegen Tinea Axillares.
Er nimmt Diclofenac-Tabletten gegen Arthrose.
Er wurde bisher noch nie operiert.
Er hat Allergie gegen Pferdehaare, die sich durch Chloritis und Wüspne äußert.
Er hat auch Penicillin-Allergie, die sich durch Angioedema mit Wüspne äußert.
Er ist Raucher. Er rauchte seit 3 Jahren 5-6 Zigaretten täglich.
Früher hat er eine Schachter Zigaretten täglich 30 Jahre lang geraucht.
Er trinkte 1-2 Flaschen Bier täglich.
Er trinkte regelmäßig 1 Flasche Bier am Wochenende.
Früher hat er 1-2 Flaschen Bier täglich getrunken.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater mit 69 Jahren an Sinuskarzinom verstorben sei.
Die Mutter sei bettlägerig, habe Druck, Geschwur und wohne in einem Pflegeheim.
Er habe 2 gesunde Geschwister und sei seit 18 Monaten verwitwet.
Er hat 2 Kinder, die Tochter leidet an Angststörungen.
Er sei Sozialdienst-Angestellter von Beruf.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf ein Tier aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter vertigo hyperhidroso Tremor, Rhetsograde-Amnesie, Parasthesie in den Fingern, Tachycardie in der Unruhe, Sehstörungen.
Diese Symptome sprechen für ein Tier.
Jetzt hat er diese Beschwerden oder jetzt alles ist ordentlich?
Der Patient hat gesagt, dass er an Parasthesie, Tachycardie in der Unruhe und Sehstörungen leidet.
Er möchte leiden, aber Rhetsograde-Amnesie ist im Moment nicht vorhanden.
Er ist im Moment auch disorientiert.
Dieser Befunder spricht auch für ein Tier.
Als Ziffernziole-Diagnose kommen Hypoglychämie, Gehirnblutung, Gehirntumor in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei dem Patienten die Vitalparameter überwachen.
Ich würde die Pupillenwerke kontrollieren und ich würde die Glasgow Coma-Skala überprüfen.
Ich würde auch bei dem Patienten körperliche Untersuchung und neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der neurologischen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Störungen der Sensorik oder andere Funktionen verliegen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Tremor, Hyperhydrose, Hautfarbeveränderungen, kalter Schweiß vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laborntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild-CAP-BSG, Blutzuckerwerte, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyten, Herz-Enzyme bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine CT-DES-CHAEDALS durchführen, um die möglichen Blutungen oder Tumore zu beurteilen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine MRT-DES-CHAEDALS durchführen, um die TIA zu bestätigen.
Und ich würde auch bei den Patienten eine EEG durchführen, um die elektrische Aktivität des Gehirns genau zu beurteilen.
Ich würde auch eine EKG schreiben, um die Herzprobleme auszuschließen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten Stationen aufnehmen.
Und ich würde den Patienten einen Vinosumzugang legen.
Und ich würde Flüssigkeit zuvor, Intravenose-Glykose verabreichen.
Was heißt Intravenose-Glykose?
Also Dexvose 20% oder 5% – ich bin mir nicht sicher, Herr Oberarzt.
Je nach den Ergebnissen von Blutzuckerwerte.
Und ja, ich würde ein neurologisches und endokrinologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Welche MRT führen Sie in diesem Fall durch?
Divisiongewichtete Magnetikresonance Tomographie.
Können Sie uns aufklären?
Divisiongewichtete – also das ist eine MRT-Untersuchung.
Und diese Untersuchung hilft uns den Entzündungen, Blutungen oder anderen Veränderungen.
Blutungen gibt es nicht.
Durchverlustung oder Entzündung?
Entzündungen, ok. Genauso erkennen.
Also MRT beruht mit Magnetismus.
Also diese Untersuchung benötigt keine Strahlenbelastung und ist völlig schmerzfrei.
Der Patient soll etwa 30 Minuten in einer MRT-Röhre ruhig liegen.
Und wenn der Patient Platzangst hat, können wir den Patienten Beruhigungsmittel geben.
Dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung und es gibt keine Komplikationen bei dieser Untersuchung.
Aber es gibt einige Kontraindikationen.
Also wenn der Patient eine Herzschriftmacher oder Metallimpilantate oder andere Metallkörperteile hat, ist eine MRT bei dem Patienten kontraindikativ.
Und nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Einschränkungen und der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Diese Untersuchung kann die Beweglichkeit des Wassermolekules im Gewebe sichtbar machen.
Und mit dieser Untersuchung können wir die Entzündung oder Durchblutung im Gehirn diagnostizieren.
Welche Befunde erwarten Sie in diesem Fall?
Also ich denke wir können bei der MRT ein hypoechoiger Gehirngewebe...
Meinen Sie, wir erwarten auf einen Schlaganfall im Gehirn?
Ja, genau.
Wegen einer Durchblutstörung können wir eine Lokale der Kruse...
Das bedeutet ein Populist Schlaganfall.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, ich denke als Verdachtdiagnose, ja denken.
Aber Sie erwarten auf einen Schlaganfall?
Also eine Blutung, eine aktive Blutung können Schlaganfall aber auch Populist-Seru-Sachen.
Aber das ist keine Blutung, das ist nur eine Durchblutstörung.
Wir sehen keine andauerte Probleme beim Gehirn.
Herr Kollegen, wenn wir in diesem Fall denken, erwarten wir ein normales Gehirn im MRT.
Das bedeutet jetzt alles in Ordnung. Der Patient hat keine Beschwerden jetzt.
Und die Beschwerden des Patienten dauert ungefähr 1, 2, 3 bis 24 Stunden lang.
Dann ist alles in Ordnung. Denken wir, trans-terrorische ischämische Attacke.
Aber jetzt hat er Parasit, Parasit, Hemiplegien und wir erwarten auf einen Schlaganfall.
Verstehen Sie mich?
Ja, danke für diese Informationen, Herr Oberhans.
Also der Patient leidet unter nur Parasit. Also es gibt keine Parasit oder andere große Probleme.
Ich denke, das ist kein Apoplex. Ja, ich denke, das ist ein Tierfall.
Aber es gibt keine Schmerzen. Wenn der Patient Hypokalisem hat, dann hat er auch keine Schmerzen.
Ja, okay. Also andauernd... Ja, ich verstehe.
Andauernd...
Also andauernd...
Ja, nach der Glykose- oder Dextrose-Infusion können wir eine Entscheidung treffen.
Okay, sehr vielleicht.
Sehr vielleicht.
Und ich gratuliere Sie, gehen Sie auf unser Infodisk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikat.
Danke Ihnen, Herr Oberhans. Sie sind sehr nett.